[Music]
kim kardashian and north west show off
their amazing makeup skills
it's always so much fun the mother
daughter duo shared this video of
themselves on tick-tock putting on
special effects makeup
that's kim and north wearing red and
black makeup and adding prosthetic
tissue to their face
talk about some serious creativity
thank you
earlier in the day north went solo to
rock another special effects look
[Music]
and she posted the final reveal in this
video
[Music]
back in april kim gushed over how
talented north is posting this pic on
instagram alongside the caption quote my
creative baby and i love seeing the look
she creates
north's love of makeup is something the
beauty and fashion mogul talked to e.t
about in 2018. she really isn't to
beauty she loves hair looks that's her
thing and she loves a little bit of
makeup
well seems north can continue posting
her makeup videos as long as she doesn't
go live on the app
mom i'm live
the eight-year-old got herself into
trouble earlier this week when she went
live without her mom's permission
and her cousin kourtney kardashian's son
mason disick agrees
on tuesday kim shared this text she
received from her 12 year old nephew kim
not only agreed with mason but also
praised him for being so mature and
called him an insightful king
i love that in the meantime hopefully
north will be staying off those
tick-tock lives and will continue to
make fun videos with her mama
[Music]
you